hi I'm Josh Condon senior editor of
details magazine I'm here with Rachel
Nick's lead instructor at VFX studio and
today we are going to talk about sex
specifically what you should be doing in
the gym to get better at it
Rachel what do we need to know I feel
like flexibility is huge which might
mean telling not my maybe a little bit
too much about my preferences in the
bedroom but flexibility stamina right
and then balance if you're having a
little extra fun so um let's see a great
way to work on flexibility and stamina
or kettlebell swings so grab your
kettlebell feet a little bit wider than
hip width now with the swing it's all
about the hip hinge the bend and snap of
the hips which I feel people get afraid
of
so notice right josh is snapping his
hips and I like to say a lot of times
you want to see the dimples in the booty
every time you thrust the kettlebell
forward so it's the snap of the hips and
the swing of the kettlebell not the
other way around because if you swing at
the hips then you overextend and crunch
in your low back how does that feel
feels great yeah got that little hip
meet the hip movement you have which a
lot of people I think are afraid of I
hop and cue it is you have to be
aggressive in the hips so that works for
Cirque yes that works for sex
I've doggie style comes to mind but you
know whatever works um so that's one and
then working on stamina and balance I
love single leg drivers so I'm an
athlete and I feel like I channel my
inner track star that I never really was
you're gonna have to show me though okay
so channel your inner track star right
so opposite elbow to opposite knee so
let's start left knee up right elbow up
so first just start kind of slow motion
you kick back you tap the floor with the
left hand and then you come right back
up I like to like find a point to focus
on and then you add the hop add the hot
add the hop so you have balance you have
stamina and then you have flexibility
from the hip hinge I'm not great at that
one
practice makes perfect I
I'm Rachel Nick's lead instructor at VFX
studio and you're watching details calm